we have seen the heartbreaking images
from Australia everybody's been probably
keeping up with that and where the fires
have just devastated that country 18
million acres burned 3,000 homes were
destroyed and probably the most shocking
statistic of all is up to a billion
animals may have lost their lives which
is so sad look at oh my gosh
I've watched the news and like all of
you my heart breaks for the people of
Australia but where there is tragedy
there are always people that are helping
and including the Irwin family they
operate the Australia Zoo which has
taken in tens of thousands of animals
you might remember I had bindi Robert
Ann Terry on last year and so I reached
out to them for an update on their
efforts and how we here in the US could
help in any way so they're joining us in
Australia might be a little bit of a
delay it's gonna be great hey everyone
what's going on
[Applause]
they're so cute
tell us who you have here they are so
adorable we've got two little flying
foxes also known as brute or Skype
puppies they're basically our little sky
Poppins these are the ones our orphans
they are absolutely adorable and we've
seen hundreds and hundreds of fruit bats
that have been taken up to our state of
Queensland that need rehabilitation
because of the fires that are happening
down south Alyssa so maybe they were too
little to escape the fires so their
mamas flew away but then they were stuck
we've got about 700 fruit bats up here
so far Wow so some of the animals you're
caring for our extremely vulnerable
right
[Music]
so we obviously know what y'all are
doing your you know providing miracles
over there for these animals but I know
there are a lot of people here in the
u.s. that want to help so what's the
best way we can get involved like where
can we spend money or where can people
in I'll show you give time like what are
all those options sure so it's very
helpful if you want to help wildlife to
donate to wildlife warriors at wildlife
warriors org we are a charity in the
United States which means it's a
tax-deductible donation and then the
funds are transferred to Australia to
help in this emergency time so thank you
so much that way we can send care
packages of medicine and key to the
frontline of the fire we can help people
who are dealing with transporting
animals up here for help and we can get
our teams of veterinarians and
technicians down to assist as well thank
you thank you so much for just doing so
much for these animals we know that your
family loves animals and just what
you're doing is it's so important it's
so inspiring to all of us so we have
links on our website for ways people at
home can help just be sure to go to
Kelly Clarkson show comm for more info
and Terry bindi and Robert thank you all
so much again for just what you do good
luck and thank you so much for joining
us again
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this